[Musique]
Jim quoi que je fasse je le fais pour te protéger tu
vois je comprends je comprends
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regarde par ici notre rébellion est tout ce qui
reste pour repousser l'Empire
tu penses qu'il pourrait être capable de nous aider
quand était le  la dernière fois que vous avez été en
contact avec votre père, qu'est-ce que
c'est, il semble qu'il soit essentiel au
développement d'une super arme
si mon père a construit cette chose, nous devons le
trouver bien,
combien en ai-je besoin, ils demandent un
indicatif d'appel  un voyou en a écrit un, mais nous
avons affaire à des
soins mesurables
si l'Empire a ce genre de pouvoir,
quelle chance avons-nous,
nous avons l'espoir que les rébellions sont construites sur l'
espoir, nous
n'avons aucune idée de l'
arrivée de ce moment, les forces FRA
font que 10 hommes se sentent comme  une centaine
prends la prochaine chance
rebelles sur toi
le rêve